hi boys and girls welcome to the st.
Louis chess club it's nice to have you
all here
[Music]
and my name is Sunil Viera mantri I'm
going to teach you a little bit about
some tactics and I have two games that I
think you'll find very interesting you
know the object of the game in the end
of course is to checkmate the King right
and it's a lot easier to checkmate a
king if you can pull that King closer
and closer to your territory right so if
you can go in and attack him and get him
to walk forward you know take a walk see
if the sun is shining you know and the
deeper the King comes up the chess board
the easier it is going to be to
checkmate him alright so we are going to
look at two games where this happened
and the games have a personal connection
because the first game is a game that I
played and the second game is a game
that my stepson Hikaru Nakamura played
so this first game that I'm going to
show you was a game I played in 1963 so
that was a long long time ago and I was
just starting to get good but I I was
not it wasn't clear what my rating was
at the time I would say that it was
about 1,200 all right I hadn't played a
lot of tournaments and this was a game I
was playing against somebody who was
definitely a stronger player than me and
I remember going into this game I was
extremely scared and you know I thought
I would lose for sure and one of the
reasons I'm also showing you this game
is because I believe this was the
turning point in my chess career when I
won this game I realized that playing
higher rated players wasn't such a scary
deal and
that you had to go in with a positive
mindset right so whenever you go into
play don't look at somebody's rating
don't freeze because they have a higher
rating right believe that you have a
chance to win and I'll tell you and I'll
when I as I go through the game I will
show you exactly at which point I felt
that I was doing all right and where I
became more confident because as I said
starting off I wasn't so sure all right
so I also chose this game because it is
an opening that that all of you probably
start with I know when I started playing
I learned the classical games first and
that meant starting with E for and and
so that's I'm going to put this into
training so you don't see the moves and
I was white I play D for my opponent
play d5 and all of you have probably at
some point played an Italian game right
so you will recognize these moves easily
enough knight c6 Bishop c4 Bishop c5
right as you know this is called the
Italian also also known as the Joker
piano and you know I had started chess
when I was six or seven years old but I
had nobody to show me anything and I
played this position for the first six
years that I played chess without ever
knowing that this move c3 was a common
move because when I played I used to
either what would be what would be a
move that you would play Knight be very
careful of Knight xe5 you don't want to
do that
because he will take you right
aha so somebody told you something about
a center fork trick right and you think
you can play a 90 85 so I bad news for
you
it's not going to work and your cheetah
right yeah actually I'm sorry it's not
gonna work in this but I'll show you why
okay so if white plays Knight takes e5
then black will take back with his
knight and of course you want to win try
to win the piece back by no forking the
bishop and the night there you go and
that's the reason it doesn't work in
this position okay so so you see that so
let's go back so what are some normal
moves in this position let's let's see
it's hard to see here and that's so now
do I remember names Leah d3 is a common
move yes alright nothing wrong with d3
you are moving a cent upon remember when
you develop pieces you always want to
move your two Center pawns whenever
possible
what's another move that you could play
another good move in this position
Gabriel Castle see are perfectly good
castles is a very normal move someone
else give me a different move let me
back up here and DJ Knight c3 I think
you've given me all the normal moves in
this position so if you look at the the
table up there you see that the first
one 90 xe5 we've decided now we are not
going to play that right but not d3 is a
normal move castles is a normal move
and those are the two normal modes and
Knight c3 which which I just put in here
also but I didn't know that the move c3
was considered the best move in the
position nobody had ever showed this to
me you know I thought that this is not a
good move because the pawn is taking the
knight square right so if you play pawn
c3 you cannot put your knight on c3 so I
never knew about this alright okay but
so why what's the point of putting the
knight on the porn on c3 what's the
point of doing this right it's hard for
me to see that's Alex right Alex yeah so
the idea is to build a pawn chain you
all know what pawn chains are right so
here's a pawn chain starting from b2 to
c3 White's plan is to extend that pawn
chain by playing d4 and stretching that
into the center to try to take control
of the center you see but I didn't know
this move and I had just been shown this
move a little bit a little while before
this game so I thought I'll try it and
my opponent who was maybe about 500
points higher than me he played a very
interesting move here
he played Queen e7 and now I was
completely on my own because I had never
seen this move before in my life right
so whatever I had studied was not going
to help me you know I had to figure
things out for myself so when your
opponent makes a move that is not in not
in keeping with what you have studied
right what do you think you should do
what should you do when you are you know
you're in that situation among
what should you do correct the important
question is why when they do something
that you are not expecting you've got to
ask yourself why right if you can
understand why they are doing it then
the chances of finding a good reply a
much better okay so I'm gonna ask you
you've never seen this position in your
life right your intention was to build a
pawn chain going to d4
he played Queen e7 why what is he trying
to do
Oh to Castle queenside you know that's a
long way to go for that right that's not
so easy to do you have to move a bishop
out of the way you know you got to move
so you have to move the pawn then you
have to move that bishop I don't think
that's really the immediate reason okay
this has to be something a little you
know more a little more important in a
way yes by the way some of you have not
answered so and I know I'm not doing a
great job with the names but I'm trying
so make sure you all answer questions
otherwise what I'll do is I'll start
calling on you okay okay all right so so
Leah said that the reason for Queen e7
is after white plays d4 if black takes
the pawn right then whatever white
chooses to do there is a very good
chance the Queen can come down and take
that efore pawn with check do you see
that now do you understand why I put the
Queen there and so you know I thought
about this I said yeah that's it I
figured it out right that's what he's
trying to do I'm not going to let him do
that all right so what's a simple way of
handling this for me
circuit
well you know I don't know no no no no
I'm I'm white right
he played Queenie seven it's White's
turn right so you need to give a move
for white all right and that's okay and
next sitting next to lea
this is Sanvi right yes Sunmi what do
you think absolutely
hey he wants to take that pawn with
check right let's just get the King out
of there you know then we don't have to
worry about it anymore then if he wants
to steal that pawn we may even be able
to put a rook on Yvonne and and pin him
right so yes so that's what I did I
Castle and at this point he played d6
and now I can go back to the original
plan on d4 so does everybody understand
right now what's happening and you see
he did something a little bit different
and then you reacted to that right and
then you were able to go back to the
original plan this is extremely
important right opponent does something
different
you don't just automatically blindly
play you know what you had memorized you
see you always have to think the moment
he does something different you think
about why he did it all right okay
so now he played this move pawn takes
pawn which actually is not a really good
idea because he loses control of the
center you see how white ends up with
two pawns on the on the fourth-ranked
right and notice those two points are
side by side that makes his control of
the center very good because it it
attacks all the squares four squares in
front of those pawns right the what he
should have done is he should have
retreated the bishop immediately at the
moment you can see those two pawns in
the center and black has only one center
pond and it's only on the third rank you
see this
kind of point structure an awful lot in
games if you end up with two pawns in
the center on the fourth rank and your
opponent has one pawn on the third rank
and those are the only center pawns the
person with the two pawns in the center
has a big advantage so this is a good
structure all right and it's something
you should aim for all right now well
you should have done and I see if I let
me just try to put this in and show you
the difference if instead of taking he
moved this Bishop back notice that black
has still got a little bit more control
over the center than he had when he took
the pawn right so if he compared this
position to when he takes the pawn
you'll see the difference you see the
difference right so that first situation
was better he should have retreated the
bishop right away all right he retreats
the bishop now and I play a good normal
developing move here somebody suggests a
move for white please
sorry Knight c3 is correct I think
that's a very sensible move right and
now black plays a tricky move Bishop g4
and Bishop g4 is annoying because
correct because by pinning this Knight
it's undermining the support for the d4
pawn right and that means the d4 pawn is
in danger you see and you know this
brings up a really interesting point in
chess which is how do you handle an
attack now normally an offers reaction
when we get attacked is to either defend
ourselves
or to move away right but that's not the
only way to handle an attack
you can also handle an attack by counter
attacking you see and you know this game
this position is a very good example of
why I was not yet such a strong player
because I was worried about the D pawn
and I played a very bad move in this
position the move I would never play
today but before I showed you what I
play what I did play in this game can
you tell me what you think might be a
good move for white so let's see if I
can call on some people who haven't
really answered as most of you been
doing a really great job answering
that's Keon right go ahead h3 all right
can I understand what you're trying to
do but h3 he could still take that night
couldn't be and and then he could take
on d4 so h3 isn't really gonna work
Isabel Bishop where or Bishop g5 or
Bishop b5 pinning that night yes that's
one solution you can do that and try to
take away the pressure on d4 right I
will accept that as you know as a good
answer all right um there are other
moves that are very interesting so let's
see drew Bishop e3 okay fair enough so
let me show you that line because that's
the first move I considered and then I
decided not to do this so the reason I
didn't like Bishop e3 as much drew is
that he can still take on f3 you see and
now if I take with the Queen then the D
pawn is
not predicted well enough correct and if
I take with the porn I do keep the deep
on protected but I was a little
uncomfortable with opening up that
castle position all right Ian
understand that and that's the reason I
chose not to play Bishop III okay but
Bishop III is still a good suggestion
all right good developing move let's
call on somebody else
let's try Alan Knight d5 and and Alan
what why did you choose Knight d5 Bravo
and what's your rating Alan okay well
that move is definitely a higher rating
than 1187 all right excellent
by the way it's the absolute best move
in the position and that's what I should
have done but of course I wasn't good
enough to play that move right and I'm
stronger than I was at that time right
Knight d5 is an excellent move and
that's what I mean by a counter-attack
okay and by the way if you ever decide
to use the counter-attack try to make
sure that you're counter attacking
something that's more valuable than what
is being attacked in the first place
right does that make sense I mean if
he's attacking your rook and you
counter-attack his pawn okay
that's not very smart right but in this
case the counter-attack is on the Queen
but Alan explained it very well because
what he said was that it has a fork on
the Queen and the bishop so when the
Queen moves you could take the bishop
you see and that way the pressure on d5
has been removed all right
detail no this is
I'm sorry I'd say that sorry yes of
course
so back here yes yes you still be
threatening that right yeah it gets a
little more complicated than that but I
don't want to go into that right now
because we have a long way to go but but
I think just screen takes is is
perfectly fine in that position all
right
also pawn X actually is is possible too
because when the Queen black moves the
Queen you will be able to to take the
bishop off all right
yeah actually yes yes no this is true
and so I think the best thing to do in
this case would be to take with the pawn
so that he doesn't get the tempo when he
captures with the night all right okay
let's move on so as I said you know I
was not good enough at the time to find
the move Knight d5 I reacted to the
pressure on d4 by pushing the pond and
this had to be you know I'm lucky that I
didn't lose the game right now because
this is bad for many reasons okay so you
get to tell me exactly what is bad about
my move all right let's see what you
have to say about it so let's go to a
mug
I'm sorry no I think that's a little
slow and I think among if you do that if
your plan is to move the night and then
play C six you know I think you will be
opening the center and that will favor
white and and there is actually a
general point if I can just make this
point for a moment you put your hands
down so I can see him and then you can
in general if you are Castle right you
like the center to open up if you are
not Castle and your opponent is Castle
you don't want to open the center
because that'll help him you see so the
idea of eventually going c6 while you
are still on Castle I'm very
uncomfortable with that okay
all right so so what's so bad about my
move sanhui okay and I can go to d4 and
put pressure in the center but if you're
going to move the knight it's better to
go to a center square that's protected
rather than a center square that's on
particular you can argue this and you
can say hey wait a minute
I'll put that knight on d4 and it's
still protected by the bishop right but
there is a better center square if you
are trying to move to the same taste in
there so what is the better center
square for that night if you want to
move the knight I didn't call on you at
all and can you remind me again sorry
anujan Anoushka right ah and I you know
I missed that okay uh noise 95 is a
whole lot better and we'll see what
happens with that because that's
actually what happened in the game
ninety five is a lot better you know for
one very simple reason right what is the
one
simple reason that 95 is a better square
than 94 they are bought in the
center-right what why is that detail no
but the other one is also attacking the
knight on f3 look if I'll play an ID for
I'm attacking the knight on f3 if I play
a 95 I'm attacking the knight on f3 so
why is Knight e5 a stronger move dear ok
although the bishop on b6 is pretty
happy you know it's probably gonna stay
there for a long time right there's a
different reason I think why the e5
square is the better square okay and I
cheated and that makes a huge difference
Bravo 95 is defended by a pawn you know
when you stick a knight in the center
and you can defend it with a pawn that's
a very stable position when you're
defending it with the piece you know in
some ways your idea I mean you know that
piece is tied down to that protection
right but if you are defending it with a
pawn that you know that's a really good
situation so you want to move that night
you should move the Knight to e5 alright
so you could say that one of the things
that's wrong with my move when I push
the pawn to d5 is I freed up a really
good square for his Knight right that's
one reason but there are other reasons
why why my move is no good tell me some
other reasons why my move is not good
what else does it do it you know it's
not you should also look at whether it
hurts white or not and that's something
it does that may end up hurting white
okay
Anuj correct look I mean when you look
at it this way you see how bad this
movies
in one move I'll block up my own wish up
and open up his bishop in one move all
it took was one move right you see and
so that's why I should not play this
move I should definitely have played
what Alan suggested which is 95 okay
anyway this is what I did and he played
the move Knight e5 of course notice
they're not in addition to the pressure
on the knight on f3
there is also an attack on the bishop on
c4 the bishop is unprotected right and
so I think the move is pretty obvious
here you want to save your Bishop and
you want to give more defense to f3 at
the same time and so son V what did I
play Bishop b5 check doesn't really
answer it because in this case he could
play he could play c6 attack the bishop
if the pawn takes he could take back and
then you still end up having to play my
move so what is the the better move in
this position and Leah not Queen e2
because Queen e2 you're still in the pin
I understand why you said Queen e2
because you want to protect the bishop
right okay so that part of it is good
but I would like to get out of this pin
at the same time you know pin is very
dangerous let's go to Keon again Bishop
e2 is what I played exactly right but
you can see how my pieces are being
pushed back and in this position I think
black is doing very well
you know he should simply he could trade
off on f3 make some trades and then play
Knight f6 for example and he would be
absolutely fine and this is the turning
point of the game because you see my
opponent got a little greedy and I think
the reason this happened was because he
was 500 points high
than me and he figured he was just going
to beat me up you know strong players
have a habit of thinking that way that
they when they're playing a weaker
player you know they just want to beat
him up quickly you see and you contantly
force things interests you have to play
the position and what he should have
done you know like I said he could have
played it off and played Knight f6 but
instead he played this move Queen f6 now
this does not work and there's an
important general principle involved
here which is don't try to attack
leaving half your pieces at home I mean
this guy isn't doing anything right the
roots are not doing anything and so you
are trying to attack without completing
your development so the lesson here is
don't attack without completing your
development right not unless you have an
absolutely clear winning idea and I
realize that there was something wrong
with blacks position and remember I said
that I was really scared going into this
game well this is the first time that I
felt that I was doing okay and I'll tell
you what went through my mind once I
realized that my position was was all
right I said to myself you know thinking
you know to myself you know there's no
read no reason to be scared and I
remember thinking play the position
don't play the player right do you
understand what I mean by that right
because if you play the player then
you're gonna get scared because you know
is a better player you see so you don't
play the player you play the position
right and if the position you know if
the position is fine the position is
fine you
and once I realize that it gave me a lot
more confidence going forward you know
and then I went on I did go on to win
this game and this game is really what
made the difference because after this
game I walked out of this game saying to
myself you know I know I can beat higher
rated players you see and and that's
really got me moving okay so what I did
in this position very interestingly
right I played them all Knight takes
Knight now my opponent had seen that I
mean he's a strong player he's seen that
and what he'd seen was that when I play
Knight takes Knight it moves the knight
and there's a discovered attack opening
up to that Bishop do you see that so for
example if black wants to take my knight
if he plays Queen takes Knight or even
if he plays pawn takes Knight then I
will simply play Bishop takes Bishop and
I win a piece correct right
of course he saw that but he was
counting on another move he was counting
on doing something different he figured
if he changed if he switched the move
order then he could come out of it out
of this situation without losing a piece
so what did he play Allan absolutely he
played Bishop take c2 and now he's
thinking okay white is going to play
Queen takes Bishop you know because of
course that Bishop is attacking the
Queen and the rook is going to play
Queen takes Bishop and then you play
Queen takes Knight and everybody is
happy because it's just been a
complicated trade affair train right and
that's not what happened you see in this
position White has a really powerful
move you know you can never assume that
someone is going to recapture and that's
the mistake he made he assumed that I
was going to recapture on e 2 but
instead of recapturing I did
something he was not expecting what did
I do
Isabel Bravo you know it's always
important to look at checks you never
know when a check can cause trouble all
right
who said earlier always look at checks
and CAPTCHAs right Alan did right
absolutely true Alan right you know look
at the check
I played Queen a4 check and I knew I was
gonna win this game now because he has
maybe four reasonable or four main ways
to get out of this chicken they're all
bad so let's take the worst one first
okay
he's got to get out of this check the
worst one of course is this well of
course it's checkmate in one move right
thank you very much game over right okay
so obviously it's not gonna do that so
let's look at bad move number two this
is probably the second worst move okay
Rosa hand so I can call on you and give
everybody a chance all right so let's go
to Judea absolutely 97 check forking the
king and queen we don't need to go any
further thank you very much we're gonna
win this game okay let's try another way
to get out of this check so we've seen
two ways to get out of the check the
other move we need to look at is c6 but
this doesn't work very well either right
what's going to happen here's on V D
takes c6 obviously and a couple of
interesting lines here I mean first of
all if he plays Queen takes Knight or
even pawn takes Knight then he is in big
trouble right what's going to happen to
him now socket
discovered check right and then he's
gonna remove his skiing and then not
only do we take the rookie turns into a
queen at the same time right but there's
another interesting sideline here
supposing he plays B takes c6 of course
you play Queen takes c6 right and you
see what that is doing don't you
that's an attack on you know it's a fork
between the king and the rook he has to
play King e7 and here's now a very
interesting situation and these are
little things that can make a huge
difference in a game of chess you know
obviously you're looking at taking that
rook but you know there may be other
things you can do maybe you don't have
to take that rook you know what else can
we do detail checkmate you see no but
it's a good try and unfortunately he
will go to f8 you see and and then it's
very hard it's the Queen would be
occupying the square if you play Queen
d7 the Queen will be occupying the
square the knight really wants to get to
so there's something else we should play
here and and what is that Kian yes and
this is what we call an intermediate
move you know we may end up taking that
rook anyway but ninety five check not
only is it an intermediate move it what
else does it do it for the king and
queen right so he ends up having to play
King e6 and now remember I started off
by saying we are going to examine some
King hunts right where you're trying to
force that King to keep advancing up the
board and here's a great opportunity to
force that King to come up the board and
this definitely is an intermediate move
because you want to take his Queen but
you're not going to take your screen
right now
you're gonna do something else first and
then your Turkish Queen so you improve
your position a little bit here
by playing let's see that is that is Sun
V right I'm sorry no you you can try go
ahead what move are you thinking yeah so
you can play Queen check but that's what
you should do and if he takes the night
which he has to because he has no other
choice
now you take his screen and watch what
happens really interesting you see how
that King is just sitting in the middle
of the board now if you want to force
that King to force him deeper into white
territory right what you want to do is
to get behind him and not let him
retreat get behind him and force him to
keep moving up right now I think this is
very clear right who can tell me the
next move the next move Isabel should be
queen e7 Bravo
you see we ended up not taking his route
because we got his Queen but now you see
what's happening to his King there's
only one square he has to go to d4 right
now keep attacking him from the back
force that king to walk up the
chessboard okay Leah queen x d6 is
correct okay now make sure he does not
retreat one of the things is trying to
do is he's trying to sneak back by going
to be 5 and then maybe to a6 right we
want to make sure we cut that escape
route don't let him sneak back that way
so can you tell me the next move and
Anushka right
no sorry no that's a nice guy
this is exceed
how do we stop that king from running
back Bravo
if you understand that the principle is
to stop the King retreating then these
moves are easy to find right King c6
he's got to come forward and I'll just
show you this really funny line you know
now you can look at that King you know I
mean it's not gonna survive very long I
can tell you when the King is ahead of
all the other pieces right he's in
serious trouble but there's a very
clever move for right here he can play
this move a four do you know what the
plan is
what is the plan behind a four
let's see a mug
Ruka three check right unusual of
bringing you a rook into the game but
Rico three check desert in fact you know
if he for example this could happen
rookie three check and let's say the
King goes here Quincy to check it's kind
of like a ladder mate isn't it a ladder
mate with a lot of pieces on the board
right so if risking a one thank you
Queen d2 would be checkmate right so you
can see that all of this you know this
is a you can see how that King was
forced to come up the board so we are
back to this Queen a4 check and the one
move which we did not consider his best
move as a matter of fact and that's what
he played was King a seven and you know
earlier I think it was detail who in a
similar position suggested Queen d7
check right and was it you yeah and and
and I remember telling you no don't do
that because the knight really is
looking at that square you see and
so I could have played Queen d7 check
here but and I didn't but I played a
very strong move in this position and so
let me see if you can figure it out
without any hints or any advice from me
what do you think
let me ask Co and what's the point Co
yes yes okay so yes you are correct
the move is Bishop g5 pinning the Queen
of course he has no choice he has to
accept it right queen takes bishop and
now is called said Queen d7 check no to
see the king can no longer go back to f8
because Queen takes f7 is checkmate
right so he has to come forward and the
King hunt has begun okay you can finish
it off for me
give me the next move please Gabriel no
Alex no tell him I was just trying to
see if he was on the ball
so remember what we've been talking
about Gabriel what we want to do is to
force that King to keep moving down the
board all right or up the board
depending which way you are looking at
it you know and if a few pieces are
going to get lost along the way you
don't really care because once this King
is deep in your territory and your queen
is still on the chess board you're going
to be able to check made him pretty
easily so what do you say Gabriel
correct Queen to accept seven very good
of course you lost the knight but who
cares right all we want to do is to
force that came to keep marching up the
board right okay next move next move for
star King to keep marching up the board
Qian it's correct now he better find the
right move because if he does the wrong
one he's going to get checkmated
instantly that's the wrong move can you
show me checkmate in one move checkmate
in one move Akiva Bravo
very good night take C to his checkmate
so of course he didn't do that he went
the other way like he's supposed to King
before still Knight take C to checkmate
right and King C for now I get to see if
you understood and process something I
told you something I mentioned earlier
which is don't let the King find a way
back into his territory cut off the
retreat lines right so dear what would
you do
I'm sorry if for is a very good idea
very good idea you know it's just that
because you correctly identified the
retreat square as b5 okay and so that's
a very good suggestion the problem is
that it doesn't help your pieces get
into bed
attacking position you see this queen
eeeh that queen is now not in a good
attacking position you see and maybe you
know it's better to improve its position
so Anushka Queen to d7 is correct very
good very good Queen to d7 and tell me
why Annika yeah it cuts off b5 as a
retreat Square right yeah and just to
prove the point okay bye
do you see also how the Queen simply got
herself into a much better attacking
position by playing Queen d7 because if
I back up a move you see that Queen
wasn't really participating in the
attack correct but by playing the move
Queen d7 you know now she's threatening
to come into the game from the other
side in fact let's take an example let's
say he'd plays the move Knight f6 watch
what happens
Queen check and now the King has
virtually no defense he has two squares
he gets mated both ways okay let's take
this let's take King c5 or King b3 it
doesn't matter which one let's start
with okay let's start with King b3
can somebody figure out a mate here
fairly simple let's go to aniket rook d1
is not checkmate but it is the right
move anacott okay but it's not checkmate
because what's he gonna do yeah come
come closer come closer right and now
you're simply going to play simply going
to play yeah Gabriel rook e1 is
checkmate exactly right and so you can
see that by the way who said Queen d7
reduce Anushka right
yeah Queen d7 is what I played that's an
excellent move Queen d7 cuts off the
retreat squares and probably his best
move by the way is to play see sexy
tried that and then I played Queen takes
b7 and he had enough so he said he
resigns and and that was it you know
because obviously you can see the king
is sitting out there with no help the
queen is on the wrong side the black
Queen is on the wrong side of the board
to help his King notice also look at
that rook on a eight the rook on h8 and
the night on g8 they haven't even moved
right all of whites pieces are pretty
active this King has absolutely no hope
of surviving yes so do you understand
this game right do you see the the
lessons you know one of the things you
should do at least this is what I tell
my students to do when whenever you know
after they they have a lesson is to to
think back and write down for themselves
like all the general points you learned
from this because it's a good way of
remembering right because you are never
going to have the same position ever
happen to you right so what do you learn
from going over a game you learn you
know general points that can be applied
to other situations you see and so it's
important you know to to draw those
lessons from the games you look at it's
something you might want to do okay all
right so let's go to a more complicated
game and and this is the game that that
Hikaru played let me just get to the
critical position because we won't have
time to look at the whole thing let's
this is about a good situation okay
let's talk about the position from here
so first of all a little background
about this game it was played in
2007 I thought it was 2008 but I see it
as 2007 and it was one of acara's first
major international tournaments his
opponent al is from Poland McHale
krosang cough who was at the time it was
played was very close to 2,700 he has
been over 2700 feet eh and you can see
he karu was the lower rated player at
the time Hikaru was about 26 50 and
let's just talk about this position he
car was playing black so let me actually
show this to you from his side so I'm
gonna flip the board and black has just
played the move Queen b6 attacking the
bishop and white played route b1
perfectly understandable very normal
move he's also looking at maybe moving
this bishop away with some kind of
discovery on the Queen right okay so
Hikaru actually took this into
consideration and he completely ignored
the discovery and he played pawn takes
pawn and in this position chrushank of
thought he was actually winning the game
because he played the move knight c6 now
let's just stop and look at this
position for a moment you see everything
that black is threatening right first of
all knight c6 is protected by the bishop
on g2 of course black could play rook
takes c6 and we'll see that actually
happened in the game but apart from that
white is threatening to move this bishop
somewhere and probably where we are
going to move it to is f6 and there's
going to be the discovery attack on the
Queen right so
hikaru blurred rook takes c6 and
croissant cough plays Bishop takes f6
now look at everything that's being
attacked in this position so as I said
the car was playing black notice the
queen is under attack right the rook is
under attack from the bishop the bishop
on e7 is being double attacked by the
rook and the bishop it looks like black
is in big trouble with it because white
has all these threats you know and as I
said you know croissant cough really
thought he was winning this position
when he played Bishop takes f6 but
Hikaru had anticipated this position and
he does something that is absolutely
spectacular I think this game you know
in the future when you know a hundred
years from now it'd probably be a game
that's included in a lot of books
because the movie played was most
unexpected right look at this move he
sacks his queen now what's the point the
point is simply to you know to expose
the King of course the king could run
away but if he runs away then among
other things we could simply play rook
takes Bishop for instance like this and
I mean Black is you know very much
better right if not just winning
so naturally croissant all figures all
right well let's accept the sacrifice so
he plays King takes Queen now you just
give up your queen for a pawn ok
you better have something good so how do
you intend to continue so remember if
you make a sacrifice like this you got
to follow up aggressively and remember
what we talked about we talked about the
King hunt right we want to pull that
king closer to our territory so now
what's the move that will do that let's
try a mod Bishop c5 check do you all
agree with that Bishop c5 check pretty
good right okay but he has a choice
right he could go to f1 or he could go
to f3 now look carefully and tell me
what would happen if the King goes to f1
so in the game he actually played King
f3 so we'll come back to that let's take
a look at what might happen if the King
goes to f1 any suggestions
okay how about Isabel Bravo c3 is the
correct move because c3 Isabel tell me
why because it's a discovered check and
now you see how those two bishops you
know are just dominating the King right
so you know you would have to play
rookie - he has no other choice
and now you know never rush into things
all right you know you see a good move
we know Bishop takes rook is a
reasonable move but you just sacrifice
your queen you want to try to do the
most accurate move you want to try and
get in as much material as you possibly
can okay what is the best move for black
in this position call unfortunately that
wouldn't work okay and I'm going to show
you why okay what's this so let's say
that you player yes did you see
something so if you if black plays rook
takes f6 white will give up the bishop
and then he can probably hide his King
on g2 so for example if this happens
rook takes you know you could probably
play King G - he's still surviving right
so let's go back Luke takes f6 what else
can either he would have to play Bishop
he would have to play Bishop f3 but like
I said even he does that it'll create
the g2 squares and escape square for Ice
King so there is a better move in this
position it's not rook takes f6 Alex no
I mean I'll agree that Bishop 32 is
something that we are looking at and we
would really want to do at some point
but not immediately son we know Isabelle
know something a little bit more
attacking a little bit more of a direct
attack because don't forget whatever it
is you sacrifice your queen you know you
don't have all this time to just fool
around you gotta get that material back
oh there you go
the move is c2 and this move is an
absolute killer because the pawn is
attack it's a fork on the Queen and the
rook and of course he's gonna have to
take it because otherwise we're gonna
capture one of these two pieces the pawn
is going to become a queen and when he
takes then you simply have now you can
play Bishop takes you to check because
he cannot give back any material see if
you played remember those of you who
suggested Bishop takes e2 or rook takes
e2 earlier the problem was that white
could sacrifice his queen back right one
of the big things about being a hidden
material is that you can give it back
you see and so if you give it back and
survive then you're happy this way he's
not going to be able even to give it
back because now the only answer is for
white to go king he won and then I'm
sure you can give me the next move right
the the next move achiever
oh I think you can do a little better
than Bishop f3 maybe I mean if you are
really looking at a discovery what would
be the stronger discovery a cheater
Bishop d3 would be a stronger discovery
right and then you can see you're going
to end up coming out ahead in material
you see so going back to f1 didn't work
and and why decided he'll March is king
out and that's exactly what black wanted
you see because he was willing to give
up the Queen to draw that King out into
the open and now you've got to keep
attacking so the next move was pretty
obvious because that's with a check
notice the white king cannot go back at
all
he's so he the game actually the King
came came up to g4 okay lots of
attacking moves here let me show you the
next couple and then we'll figure out
the checkmate at the end okay black
player Knight e5 check of course why
could sacrifice his rook but if he does
after rook takes oh this is a good
question actually and see if you can
answer this without my moving the pieces
so why doesn't white simply play route
next night and on rook takes rook try to
checkmate with rookie a it'll be a check
would that work for him Isabel why not
because Bishop f8 can come back and
block the check and there is no the king
is still in a mating net right but
because bishop f8 is there there is no
checkmate so what happened in the game
was the king came to g5 Picaro played
route g6 track king went to h5 and now
you know even in the middle of attacks
and you can see that this king is really
in trouble what you what you can do is
to take away all these escape squares
and threaten to checkmate him and you
can actually do that because the king is
in such a bad position is not really
going to be able to stop it now we want
to play a rook h6 track but if we do
that the king will come to g5 correct so
can you come up with a move that will
take away the escape route right
take away the escape route Lila alia
right sorry
oh look g4 the problem with Raja folia
is that he'll sacrifice his Queen you
see so he'll give the Queen back and you
may be able to stay alive so route g4 if
I play route g4 let me just go back here
if I play rook g4 you can see he could
just play queen takes rook and now
suddenly there isn't enough attacking
power left right remember when you're
ahead in material you can always give it
back to stay alive so so let me see
let's go to this position yep so what do
you suggest let's go to our Kia Bishop
e7 you know that's a good move but what
I don't like about that is it blocks the
rooks protection of the night so he
could play rook takes Knight and
suddenly this square here becomes open
for the king you see so don't do that
okay let's go to Allan f6 is the move
right we play f6 now we are threatening
Luke h6 Jack and that's very little he
can do he tried to sacrifice
doesn't really help because this is
check and now once again what would be
the simple way to do this checkmate what
we would love to do is rook h6 check but
we know that if we play rook eight six
check the king as an escape square
correct what is the escape square that
he has on acade no that's not other
Anakin's over there sorry that was cool
let's go to how can i mix of coal and
anacott right so so tell me the escape
square what is escape square which is
the square we want to control if we want
to do this check right and we don't want
him running away
what is the escapes were to control DJ
no what is White's escape square King g4
right g4 is the escape square I agree
right so now find a way to block off the
escape square and then we are going to
check made him just like that okay
all right this time Co Bishop c8 is
correct
that's in fact Madras player I think he
resigned in this position because there
is no way to stop the checkmate this
move is simply going to be rook h6 ah
but wait supposing he tries to stop the
checkmate by doing this okay now hold on
don't give him a chance to sacrifice his
Queen how do you win this position
remember to look all over the chess
board remember to consider all the
pieces you know even forgotten ones you
know pieces that you don't like you
haven't used them in a while they're
feeling left out of the action you know
come on bring everything into the game
okay let's see
Lia Bravo you know by the way Lia that
that you've given several good answers
today okay but but it's not just that
you you got the answers it's just I can
see from the answers that you gave that
you have a pretty good view of the
chessboard
you know because because your answers
you had to actually consider the board
as a whole and you know when you see
this move it looks very obvious but it's
not at all that obvious because it's
using a different part of the board the
attack is coming from somewhere where
there was no attack earlier you see and
so that's a hard move to find so
congratulations yeah
Bishop takes f2 is a killer because
there's the only move in reply is is to
go to h3 and then of course simply
checkmate archita is rook h6 checkmate
right yeah so what I was trying to show
you with this today is the power of the
King hunt right when you bring when you
force the other person's King to come
towards your side of the board even if
you have sacrificed some material it's
not you know that much of a problem
because the closer he gets to your
position the more attackers you will
have even the pawns can become attackers
you see and so you saw the king really
didn't survive by coming up but what you
also saw today you saw lots of pins and
forks and discoveries right and I'll
leave you with this which is that I
consider I think that the three most
powerful attacks in chess are pins forks
and discovered attacks or discovered
checks and there are a lot more that go
along with those but those are the
basics right if you get
at identifying pins and forks and
discovered checks right and you put that
together with a few other ideas like a
king hunt and like battering rams things
like that you know you will find that
you will play very much better okay
great
thank you very much everybody we'll stop
there for today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]